glauben sie seien autonom kaufen den
joghurts den sie wollen
surfen im internet waren sie möchten
lesen die nachrichten die sie
interessieren
vergessen sie's sie sind nicht frei und
ihre selbstbestimmung ist bedroht das
behauptet zumindest mein heutiger gast
harald welzer und ich will doch mal
sehen ob ich mir nicht ein fässchen
freiheit zurück ergattern kann in diesem
gespräch habe der welt sei
hallo ich habe es eben meine ferien im
internet gebucht bin ich jetzt nicht
selbstbestimmt neuer das kommt darauf an
es könnte ihnen passiert sein dass sie
einen urlaub gebucht haben an dem sie
ursprünglich gar nicht gedacht haben und
er vielleicht durch das angebot des
portals sollte der portale wo sie
durchgesetzt sind überhaupt ihnen erst
in den sinn gekommen ist und dann zur
buchung gekommen ist ja wo liegt das
problem wenn ich spazieren gehen dann
kann es ja auch sein dass ich irgendwo
einen weg sehen wo ich erst gar nicht
lang gehen wollte und dann entscheide
ich mich dafür ja ja das entscheiden sie
sich in diesem fall kommt das ja
gewissermaßen nicht wie durch eine
landschaft oder durch einen fluss oder
irgendwas was so daherkommt absichtslos
sondern das angebot bekommen sie ja
absichtsvoll es möchte ja jemand dass
sie genau diesen urlaub dieses hotel
diesem flug was auch immer buchen also
insofern ist es der vergleich nicht so
ganz zutreffend
sie sprechen die sogenannten filter
bubble sun dass sich sozusagen die
treffer kriege die eben die nach meinen
präferenzen schon vor gefiltert werden
sie haben ja unsere freiheit ist richtig
bedroht durch das internet können wir
das ein bisschen aus einer unternehmen
was genau hängt denn da wie zusammen was
ist jetzt bedroht aufgrund welcher
faktoren also zunächst mal ist es ja so
dass wenn wir das internet benutzen und
das gefühl haben wir suchen nach
irgendwelchen produkten ist es ja
zunächst mal ein missverständnis bei wir
sind ja das eigentliche produkt was
interessant ist mit all unseren
eigenschaften und durch die suchbewegung
durch die kauf akte und so weiter und so
weiter liefern wir ja details über uns
als produkt
wir liefern die in dem wie sie es gerade
gesagt haben jetzt mitteilen dass sie
urlaub machen möchten dass sie die zeit
ihrer abwesenheit mitteilen dass sie das
bevorzugte land mitteilen vielleicht die
region sie teilen auch mit mit wem sie
fahren oder zumindest mit wie vielen und
so weiter und so weiter das heißt eine
ganze kaskade von mitteilungen die sie
machen und die werden natürlich
verwendet diese mitteilung die sind teil
sozusagen eines ganzen daten profils was
über sie genau über diese akte angelegt
werden so und wenn dieses daten profil
gut ist dann wird man damit arbeiten
können und entsprechend wenn sie
versuchen die nächste aktion im internet
zu machen ihnen das entsprechende
angebot zu servieren
sie sprechen jetzt immer man wird dann
angebote machen wir liefern
irgendwelchen entitäten daten aber noch
einmal wer ist denn dieses gegenüber
sodass gegenüber sind unternehmen die
möglichkeit haben mit von entsprechenden
anderen unternehmen also google oder
andere internet unternehmen diese daten
zu bekommen damit die werblich genutzt
werden können
sie gehen ja soweit unter anderen in
ihrem neuen buch autonomie eine
verteidigung das sie geschrieben haben
zusammen mit michael pauen es erscheint
im april
sie gehen so weit zu sagen dieses system
ist totalitär eine sehr steile these wie
kommen sie darauf ich glaube ich dass
die these steil es mal versuchen das zu
erklären also das worüber wir bislang
gesprochen haben ist natürlich noch
nicht totalitarismus aber es hat
elemente davon an die elemente liegen
genau darin dass sie sich als person als
nutzerin vollständig transparent machen
in ihren neigungen in ihren
verhaltensweisen in der lieferung
objektiver daten in der erklärung von
absichten und so weiter und so weiter
das heißt das was sie sich eigentlich
und ich mir natürlich auch immer
zugutegehalten haben dass es
gewissermaßen einen privaten bereich
gibt der niemanden etwas angeht es sei
denn man lässt ihn rein
dieser private bereich ist im
verschwinden begriffen sehr stark im
verschwinden begriffen
und man kann es ja sehr deutlich daran
sehen dass vor 20 jahren diese
informationen was sie als nächstes tun
möchten welche bücher sie lesen mit wem
sie sich treffen mit wem sie kontakt
haben und so weiter wo sie arbeiten und
so was das war ja außer denen die
konkret damit in zusammenhang gestanden
haben ihr arbeitgeber ihr freundeskreis
niemandem bekannt
das ist alles richtig aber warum sagen
sie der bereich des privaten ist
insgesamt dann verschwinden man kann sie
doch einfach sagen das ist eine facette
des privaten also wenn ich ferien buchen
dann wissen die etwas darüber war nicht
verreisen will wohin nicht verreisen
will die wissen anfangs noch ob ich
kinder habe ja oder nein wie viele
zimmer ich buche das war's das war es ja
nicht wenn sie einkaufen gehen oder mit
kreditkarte oder payback karte oder was
auch immer diesen einkauf dokumentieren
bei allem was ihn nicht bargeldlose was
sie nicht mit bargeld bezahlen
bei jeder theater karte die sich über
das internet reservieren lassen und so
weiter entstehen ja daten ich will jetzt
keinen verschwörerische profil hier
entwickeln aber wir wissen natürlich
dass diese daten miteinander verknüpft
werden oder es würde auch schon reichen
dass sie verknüpft war sind wie die
amerikanische philosophin schon hartz iv
sagt wenn sie verknüpft bar sind werden
sie auch verknüpft das ist eines der
gesetze der internetwelt und in der
verknüpfung liegt das potenzial das man
mehr über sie weiß als sie über sich
selber wissen und darauf sind ja dann
übrigens konzerne wie google und so
weiter stolz das sind ja setzte die
formuliert werden von eric schmidt dem
vorstandsvorsitzenden oder sowas dass
das was gutes sei dass sie mehr wissen
die googles über sie als sie selbst über
sich wissen zum beispiel dass sie nicht
wissen was sie als nächstes kaufen
werden dass wir sind die aber schon
also das heißt das problem wäre
sozusagen die kumulation von
bestellvorgängen im internet nicht der
einzelne akt des ferien buchen
aber wenn wir noch einmal zurückgehen
zum totalitarismus problem genau sie
haben ja lange zeit geforscht zum thema
totalitarismus in der ns zeit noch
einmal wenn man jetzt hitler vergleicht
mit google dahinter vergleicht
natürlich hängt der weil wir diese figur
des diktators nicht haben
und weil wir die figur der
machtübernahme nicht haben es gibt gar
keinen systemwechsel scheinbar ist ja
alles noch zumindestens in
gesellschaften unseres typs immer noch
rechtsstaat und demokratie jetzt kommt
aber ein entscheidender punkt wo die
sache wirklich interessant wird was
bedeutet es für eine gesellschaft wenn
das private verschwindet was bedeutet es
für eine moderne gesellschaft die
demokratisch und rechtsstaatlich ist
wenn das private verschwindet und das
ist glaube ich der entscheidende punkt
den man verstehen muss wir haben ja so
etwas wie eine private person erst mit
dem aufstieg moderner gesellschaften
wenn ich vorher leibeigener bauer bin
dann bin ich in dem sinne nicht privat
weil man über mich verfügen kann
beispielsweise wenn ich in extreme
abhängigkeit existiere bin ich nicht
privat weil man über mich verfügen kann
moderne gesellschaften zeichnen sich
dadurch aus dass es eine private sphäre
und eine öffentliche sphäre gibt und das
hängt damit zusammen dass wir privatheit
brauchen um uns austauschen zu können
gedanken machen zu können pläne
entwickeln zu können und so weiter in
einem nicht öffentlichen raum und das
genau darum um dann als öffentliche
person auch auftreten zu können und
sagen als bürger als bürgerin möchte ich
mich einbringen ihnen diese öffentliche
sphäre dadurch zeichnet sich eine
moderne bürgerliche gesellschaft auf das
private verschwindet wird es identisch
mit dem öffentlichen das heißt die ganze
substanz dessen was wir in modernen
verfassung staaten haben ist radikal in
frage gestellt und es ist ja interessant
sich anzuschauen dass alle verfassungen
von der amerikanischen verfassung ab die
unverletzlichkeit der person die
unverletzlichkeit der wohnung als
höchste verfassungsgut haben und das ist
ja total interessant und wir verfügen
durch diese reale entwicklung wie sie
jetzt geschieht nicht mehr über die
unverletzlichkeit unserer person und
unserer privatsphäre was meinen sie mit
dass verletzlichkeit der person also
wenn ich zum beispiel dem wir wieder ein
zitat von eric schmidt wenn man nicht
will dass etwas über einen kommuniziert
das vielleicht unangenehm ist dann
sollte man es nicht tun
also ist eine direkte einwirkung wenn
ich jetzt bestimmte vorlieben hegel oder
dazu neige zu viel alkohol zu trinken
oder keine ahnung eine stein sammlung
habe als größte passion und das
irgendwie peinlich ist dass meine
persönlichkeit darauf zusammenzufassen
ist das deine stein sammlung hat oder
wie auch immer nehmen sie was sie wollen
dinge von denen niemand etwas wissen
soll weil sie sich privat reservieren
aber das gibts doch nach nach wie vor
also die meisten leute werden durchsagen
mit privatheit verbindet man eben nicht
alleine die frage möchte ich gerne dass
möglicherweise daten darüber gesammelt
werden wohin ich in die ferien fahre was
ich kaufe was meine präferenzen
vielleicht sind bezüglich musikstil
sondern auch was passiert hinter meiner
schlafzimmertür was trage ich unter
meiner jeans aber auch solche dinge wie
das denke ich eigentlich welche
religiösen überzeugungen habe ich mit
wenig privat liiert und das können die
uns doch weiterhin es euch sagen für uns
behalten man ist ja frei darin und sagen
beziehungsstatus gleich im internet
rausposaunt ja kommt auch den privaten
bereich noch für sich behaupten ja jetzt
wird die sache ja sehr interessant ich
habe gerade vorhin noch mal einen
artikel gelesen zufällig in der zeitung
über industrie 4.0 und das internet der
dinge
ja weil jetzt alle großen unternehmen
egal ob die jetzt kühlschränke
produzieren oder heizungsanlagen oder
sonstwas intensiv damit beschäftigt sind
dass alle diese gerätschaften
miteinander vernetzt werden müssen weil
das ist der große trend der zukunft auch
so ein trend dem cello - kenia wieder
heraus gestrichen hat dieses internet
der dinge ja genau und das ist hört sich
ja auch wie alles in dieser schönen
neuen welt unheimlich attraktiv an weil
da ja die fantastische utopie daraus
entsteht dass mein kühlschrank schon
weiß dass die milch zu ende geht und
dann autonomen schon mal bei amazon oder
sonstwas oder bei irgendeiner es doch
eigentlich super wenn man das so sagen
mir eine sms schreibt milch fehlt mir
jetzt eigentlich passen
sie sind da noch ein bisschen langsam
aber ganz wichtig in diesem artikel den
ich vorhin gelesen habe war auch von
einer deutschen firma die innovation das
wenn man die kühlschranktür schließt das
automatisch ein foto des inneren des
kühlschrank macht und dieses foto einem
per dia ist das mms auf das smartphone
geschickt wird so dass ich auf meinem
smartphone gucken kann und denken kann
keine milch mehr
und dann kann es losgehen und das fand
ich jetzt als jemand der eigentlich sehr
weit entfernt von solchen sachen ist und
das auch gar nicht gut findet wahnsinnig
naiv weil das setzt jedoch voraus dass
es sie als subjekt was dann entscheidet
auch heute möchte ich gar keine milch
das interessiert mich nicht das foto
noch ein solches objekt voraussetzt die
nächste stufe ist er schlicht und
ergreifend die dass sie gar nicht mehr
gefragt werden sondern nach ihren
präferenzen der kühlschrank die
mitteilung macht milch fehlt und an
einen zulieferer bei dem sie bevorzugt
kaufen aber eher welt sah ich jetzt
wissen glaube ich doch immer einen
schritt zurück wir sind bei der frage
was heißt eigentlich autonomie und was
hat das zu tun mit dem internet
stichwort totalitarismus jetzt gehe ich
ein ich mit ihnen wenn ich nicht mehr
diejenigen treffer im internet kriege
die ich eigentlich wirklich wollte also
ich werde ich mit dieser filter bubble
wird schon vorgefühlt hat was mögliche
interessante 4 in die nation sein
könnten dann beschneidet das zumindest
meine möglichkeit mich selber zu
informieren was schneidet irgendwas ab
von der autonomie aber wenn wir jetzt
noch einmal autonomie und privatheit
zusammenbringen ich habe das gefühl sie
verknüpfen das in einer art und weise wo
ich das den eindruck gab es geht mir
noch zu schnell
ach so ja aber bleiben wir doch dann mal
wirklich bei der beschreibung dessen was
passiert und das ist ja exakt an dem
fall wo die vision besteht des menschen
nicht mehr erst entscheiden müssen ja
welchen welches nahrungsmittel sie
brauchen sondern dass das schon
automatisch gewissermaßen geliefert wird
und wenn ich nach hause komme und den
kühlschrank aufmache
dann steht schon da oder zumindest steht
es vor der tür und ich kann es rein
tragen
andere aspekte aus derselben vision sind
ja die dass der nicht das büro verlasse
ein thermostat zu hause mit dem auto
verkoppelt ist und dass sich einsteigen
so dass das auto meldet der kommt jetzt
bitte auf 21 grad hochfahren oder wenn
man die klimaanlage hat das runterfahren
so und das sind ja alles dinge die in
meine entscheidungsfähigkeit eingreifen
und zwar radikal sollte entscheiden sich
aber dazu diese geräte zu kaufen und
wenn ja ob man eingreifen darf ja aber
nun schauen sie jetzt gibt es
verknüpfungen die ja ziemlich
interessant sind zum beispiel wird ja
diese form des smart homes wie das dann
heißt wird ja annonciert unter dem motto
energieeffizienz kampf gegen den
klimawandel
ja es geht ja alles systema von ihnen es
geht alles nur darum alles besser zu
machen ja wir haben die mittel den
klimawandel zu bekämpfen
die leute sollen häuser haben wo sich
die energie automatisch wunderbar
effizient irgendwie macht man muss nicht
den ganzen tag heizen sondern das auto
sagt so und so weiter aber genau damit
passieren ja zwei dinge nämlich der eine
aspekt dass immer ihr verhalten gescannt
wird und als informationen selber
weiterverwendet wird es könnte ja sein
dass sie einmal nicht nach hause kommen
oder sowas dann wird das auch
registriert werden und sie werden bei
allen dingen egal ob sie dies wärmer
oder kälter haben möchten oder ob sie
heute keine milch möchten sondern die
wir vielleicht ein glas wein oder sonst
was sozusagen immer mit einer
vorgestellten sieht ua vor eingestellten
situationen zu tun haben und gar nicht
mehr wie es heute gott sei dank noch der
fall ist zu sagen ich bin ein freier
mensch
ich möchte heute mal gar nichts
konsumieren oder ich finde das total gut
wenn es warm ist wenn ich nach hause
komme bei mir geht's heute irgendwie so
dass ich es gerne wahnsinnig warm haben
mich liebst denn das subjekt das sagt
vielen dank nette möglichkeiten ich
mache da nicht mit wie es in zukunft
nicht mehr geben oder warum sagen sie
hier steht auf dem klappentext ohne
autonomie geht es nicht um die zeit
drängt also die welt steht sozusagen vor
der tür kann ich mich dem nicht
entziehen
natürlich können wir uns
entziehen sonst bräuchten wir nicht
darüber zu sprechen aber hier geht es
erst mal nur um den versuch einer
beschreibung nicht dessen was da
passiert wo wir gerade reden das wissen
wir ja alle ja also jede app die sie auf
ihrem smartphone haben erfasst daten
über sie und sie haben dem zugestimmt in
den geschäftsbedingungen und so weiter
wir wissen dass diese geschichten mit
den smart homes und so weiter in den
fantasien der investoren genauso drin
sind wie in denen die für ökologisches
bauen oder es aber es sind ja das sind
alles dinge die weil sie technisch
möglich sind als möglichkeiten auch
realität werden könnten
das interessante ist dass sich das so in
unsere lebenswelt einschleicht im
unterschied sind wir vorhin acht
gespräche gesagt zutreffender weise
hitler und google sind zwei vollkommen
verschiedene sachen das kann man ja
nicht vergleichen aber auch hier ist
natürlich ein unterschied wenn ich einen
eine sogenannte machtergreifung habe im
januar 1933 dann ist es eine zäsur
wer auch wenn sie im fühlen der leute
nicht so groß war wie sich historisch
erscheint aber es nicht sind zäsur man
weiß hier ist was anderes los mit diesen
ganzen dingen mit denen wir es jetzt zu
tun haben
die schleichen sich ja so in unsere
lebenswelt 1
sie schleichen sich ein sie schleichen
sich auch deswegen ein weil sie
wahnsinnig attraktiv sind weil sie
scheinbar das leben erleichtern
und weil sie auch faszinierende technik
gadgets sind mit denen man auch gerne
rum spielt und so das heißt es kommt
alles unheimlich freundlich daher und
die die leute von google von facebook
von airbnb dass es da immer gibt die
sagen ja auch ohne unterlass das ginge
nur um die verbesserung der welt geht
nur um die verbesserung der welt und
deshalb ist es schon teil unserer
lebenswelt ohne dass wir überhaupt
darüber nachgedacht haben wie es unsere
lebenswelt verändert und zu welchen
zwecken das zu verändern dass ich mich
eigentlich bei einem anderen
interessanten punkt also nehmen wir mal
an sie haben recht unsere freiheit ist
bedroht warum wehren wir uns dann nicht
nur sagen sie na ja einerseits es ist
einfach unglaublich bequem
es ist unglaublich attraktiv diese
sachen zu nutzen also mit dem wären
vielleicht muss man da auch ein bisschen
historisch nüchtern sein wann wären sich
leute
sie wehren sich dann wenn sie etwas
erleiden
ja aber nicht wenn sie einen scheinbaren
vorteile haben oder wenn ihr leben nach
äußerlichen anschauen mehr oder weniger
gleich bleibt also wenn man wieder das
beispiel von totalitären gesellschaften
nimmt die funktionieren ja so dass sich
gesellschaften aufteilen in leute die
zugehörig sind und leute die nicht
zugehörig sind wer in solchen
gesellschaften leidet sind die nicht
zugehörigen weil die werden bekämpft
verfolgt getötet drangsaliert was auch
immer während die zugehörigen ja
zunächst mal von dem diesen neuen zeiten
entweder fasziniert sind oder direkt
profitieren dass ein aspekt den man
immer vergisst das heißt man muss
eigentlich mal gucken was sind
eigentlich anlässe sich zu wehren dann
stehen leute auf und leute stehen
wirklich dann auf wenn sie direkt in
ihren lebensumständen einen nachteil
erleiden oder wie in der arbeiter
bewegung oder in der frauenbewegung
sozusagen in einer permanent schlechten
position sind und beginnen zu kämpfen um
diese position zu der situation in der
wir jetzt hin wird keiner drangsaliert
bezüglich der internetgeschichte jetzt
eben dass das ist ja sozusagen diese
welt verbesserungs diktatur wenn ich es
mal so sagen würde aber die kommt halt
unwahrscheinlich freundlich daher
na wunderbar man muss jetzt nicht mehr
ich wie es vorhat vor gar nicht langer
zeit gewesen ist bei der bahn anrufen um
eine fahrplanauskunft zu haben und hängt
da zehn minuten in der warteschleife
sondern da hat man sein smartphone und
guckt schnell drauf man muss nicht
recherchieren wie ist das wetter
möglicherweise an dem ort wo ich morgen
sein werde sondern klick ja also das
heißt es wird zwar keine gruppe
drangsaliert aber wie alle lassen uns
drangsalieren
wir lassen uns nicht drangsalieren wir
eröffnen die möglichkeit uns
drangsalieren zu lassen also ob wir uns
im moment drangsaliert fühlen
ein gewisser weise eine geschmacksfrage
ich persönlich fühle mich extrem leicht
drangsaliert deshalb will ich gar kein
smartphone haben ich werde auch nie 1
weil dieses gerät mir viel zu viel
abfordern also ich hasse es schon wenn
mein laptop mir mitteilt dass das jetzt
ein update macht ohne dass ich wollte
kein update haben ja oder wenn ich
gefragt werde
das heißt ich möchte mit geräten gar
nicht kommunizieren da habe ich ein
subjektives gefühl der drangsalierung
bei anderen ist es weitaus entspannter
aber es ist noch gar nicht der
entscheidende punkt ich glaube der
entscheidende punkt ist wirklich das
sich über diese veränderung dieser
kommunikativen welten und gebrauchs
formen der dinge unser sozialverhalten
verändert und unsere subjektivität sich
verändert und ein punkt der in diesem
zusammenhang auch immer wichtig ist sich
dieses phänomen des konformismus der
anpassung und in diesem buch gehen sie
auch wiederum ein auf dieses berühmte
experiment von stanley milgram dass in
diesem kontext ja dann immer genannt
wird der psychologe stanley milgram hat
in den 1970 er jahren ja experimente
gemacht zum thema totalitäre
gesellschaften und sie sehen uns
original bilder aus jener zeit an
da sehen wir wie dieser versuch
funktioniert hat es gab testpersonen die
schlüpften in die rolle der lehrer die
wurden angewiesen den schülern
stromstöße zu verpassen wenn sie fehler
gemacht haben in der beantwortung von
fragen diese schüler waren nur
schauspieler was mussten aber wiederum
diese testpersonen diese lieber nicht
das erschreckende daran wahr ist dass
sie in der dosis der stromschläge immer
höher auf dienen bis schlussendlich zu
einer tödlichen dosis vor allem dann
wenn der versuchsleiter sie dazu
angetrieben hat was ist dieses medium
experiment der welt sei was würden sie
denn sagen was ist für sie der anlass
über dieses experiment wieder zu
sprechen jetzt in dieser in dieser zeit
in der wir so viel diskutieren über das
internet ja das ist wirklich gute frage
weil man daran viel illustrieren kann
keine dieser versuchsperson an dem
experiment hatte von sich das bild
grundlos andere menschen verletzen oder
gar töten zu können oder dass zu wollen
es bedurfte einer ganz simplen
versuchsanordnung immerhin zwei drittel
dieser versuchspersonen dazu zu kriegen
anderen menschen tödliche stromschläge
scheinbar gottseidank zuzufügen ja und
warum haben die das gemacht weil hier
der besondere trick an den medium
experiment gewesen ist dass sie niemals
die aufforderung zu beginn bekommen
haben bestrafen sie denn jetzt mal mit
220 volt oder gar mit 450 volt sondern
dass der ganze versuch extrem harmlos
angefangen hat ist ein subtiler
versuchsaufbau die sind ja sogar die
versuchsperson die richtige hat ja einen
stromstoß selber bekommen druck von 30
wollt oder sowas um zu zeigen die
apparatur funktioniert und so weiter und
so weiter
er hat die scheinbare versuchspersonen
also die den schauspieler vorher auch
kennengelernt es gab gewissermaßen
persönlichen kontakt dann findet der der
versuch statt die eine person sitzt in
einem raum und der so genannte lehrer
der die stromschläge geben in einem
anderen raum das heißt der persönliche
kontakt ist weg und dann ist bei der
ersten viel antwort dieser
versuchsperson ist die erste strafe 15
volt das ist nichts
die nächstes 30 die nächste ist 45 und
so weiter geht das sukzessive und
insofern schleicht sich etwas ein in das
verhaltensmuster was bis zu einem
bestimmten punkt völlig ordnungsgemäß
und total klasse funktioniert niemand
denkt etwas bewegen so genannten
shifting basslines oder die sich langsam
ändern in einer gesellschaft wenn man
jetzt übertragen würde auf unsere zeit
wenn man das so übertragen
aber der wirklich spannende punkt bei
mehreren ist der in dem augenblick wo
die versuchspersonen die scheinbare der
schauspieler beginnt zu protestieren das
war ja alles teil des projektes weil man
wissen wollte was machen die eigentlich
wären es jetzt widerstand gibt ja wenn
der protestiert bei über 100 volt und
sagt aus oder sowas in der art was macht
dann der arme typ der die stromstöße
weitergeben muss der jetzt in einer ganz
schwierigen entscheidungssituationen
weil der hat sich schon bis dahin
siebenmal für die handlung entschieden
die er dann auch vollzogen hat wenn er
das jetzt abbrechen würde müsste er
alles in frage stellen was er vorher
gemacht hat das heißt er ist schon
richtig in diese situation rein gesurft
um es mal so modern zu formulieren was
extrem schwer da wieder rauszukommen und
deshalb wenden die sich und das der
spannende punkt an den versuchsleiter
die meisten dieser versuchsperson sind
keine stoischen befehlsgeber oder keine
sadisten sondern sie sagen oh da gibt es
ein problem der mann hat schmerzen
sollen wir den versuch nicht abbrechen
dann sagt der versuchsleiter machen sich
keine gedanken
ja die verantwortung liegt bei uns und
außerdem erfordert das experiment dass
sie weitermachen so dann entscheidet er
sich für den nächsten und so geht das
weiter
und wo ich jetzt die parallele zum netz
die parallele zum netz ist dass wir
einen weg zurücklegen wo in keiner weise
irgendetwas nicht also was bedrohliches
oder sowas im horizont erscheint sondern
wir erleben erst mal die vorteile
das ist alles irgendwie düfte und es hat
auch kein regime wechsel gegeben es hat
den punkt der aufmerksamkeit oh gott
jetzt passiert etwas fürchterliches noch
gar nicht gegeben noch nicht mal der
pfalz noten hat dazu ausgereicht ja dass
man kollektiv das gefühl hatte war da
passiert etwas anderes mit uns und da
liegt die parallel und die parallele
liegt auch dort wo man sehen kann dass
mitmenschen sehr schnell etwas passieren
kann womit die selber gar nicht
gerechnet haben ja und dann befindet man
sich gewissermaßen einen anderen soziale
situation hatte ein anderes verhältnis
und entscheidet sich zu dingen die man
der eigenen persönlichkeit gar nicht zu
rechnen würde
man könnte sagen wenn wir die frage
stellen warum wehren wir uns nicht
wehren uns nicht lage gar nicht
mitkriegen dass sozusagen die schwelle
immer höher geht wir machen da einfach
mit wir schwimmen sozusagen mit dem
strom
man denkt an nichts böses so schlecht
kann man das mal formulieren die
versuchsperson haben in den ersten
stufen des versuchs an nichts böses
gedacht aber sie denken jahren etwas
böses für sie ist da vorne irgendwo das
böse im anzug was wenn ich das einfach
nicht glauben wenn ich ihm sagen moment
mal erstens waren wir sind freie bürger
wir können uns irgendwann in die quere
stellen und sagen es reicht wir wollen
andere gesetze
es gibt ja ganz viele politiker die sich
jetzt so entsprechend äußern die müssen
auch daran denken dass 2013 im zuge der
nsa auf faire ja beispielsweise juli zeh
und trojanow gemeinsam diesen offenen
brief verfasst haben hat gesagt wir
wollen unsere freiheit zurück kommen im
namen der demokratie
man hat den eindruck es gibt stimmen die
sich da erheben
aber es scheint mir nicht schlimm genug
zu sein was das eine massenbewegung wird
also ich weiß nicht ob alle leute den
eindruck haben ist kommt nach vorne
wirklich was schlimmes auch hier würde
ich sagen denken sie an die russische
revolution denken sie an die
nationalsozialistische revolution haben
die bevölkerungsmehrheit zu diesen
zeiten gedacht da kommt jetzt was ganz
schlimmes
die haben gedacht das finden wir total
super oder teile haben gedacht das ist
jetzt aber wirklich total unangenehm da
sehen wir mal wie es weitergeht
wir können über über die die sogenannte
machtergreifung der nationalsozialisten
war sebastian haffner nachlesen
geschichte an als gold wieder diesen
vergleich google und nutzen natürlich
aber ich mache ihnen strukturell ich
mache ihn nicht personal ein strukturell
ist es so dass bei der wir wissen dann
immer aus der geschichte die es ganz
schlecht ausgegangen die geschichte
totalitäre systeme haben millionen von
menschen leben vernichtet am ende das
wissen wir
das wissen aber die leute zu anfang
nicht und warum wissen sie es nicht weil
es so zustimmungsfähig harmlos für die
zugehörigen dazu daherkommt also da ist
auch noch nichts böses drin und die
dynamiken die sich
das dann entwickelt sind auch welche die
man von anfang an gar nicht sehen kann
ein bild was ja immer zitiert in diesem
zusammenhang mit dem letztlich das
panoptikum also eigentlich diese idee
die jeremy benzen der britische
philosoph skizziert hatte wurde vielfach
aufgenommen unter anderem von michel
foucault sie wissen das besser als ich
in diesem panoptikum ist idee es gibt
eine art gefängnis in der mitte ein
überwachungs tun von dem aus man alles
überblicken kann die schreckliche
vorstellung ist für die gefangenen alles
wird gesehen
jetzt kann ja sagen heute ist nicht
sozusagen die disziplinierung der
gefangenen von uns internetsurfern das
problem sondern die idee ist ja
eigentlich marketing was man ja machen
will ist alle diese leute beobachten
damit man ihnen die produkte besser
verkaufen kann finden sie ist ein
komplett neuer rief in einer hingeht und
sagt mensch ich finde das einfach okay
ich mache diesen trailer für mich ich
weiß die sammeln daten über mich aber
mein gott für mich ist das okay ich
krieg da für die besseren produkte
ich krieg das smartphone mit dem ich zum
beispiel neben strom sparen kann mit dem
ich mir nicht so viel überlegen muss man
nicht haben einkaufen gehen muss und so
weiter finden sie dass eine komplett
neue hat und ja also das finde ich eine
komplett neue halt sondern das bild ist
ja in dem falle auch sehr schön und das
beispiel ist auch sehr zutreffend weil
es tatsächlich für die gefangenen das
allergrößte problem gewesen ist
sozusagen permanent beobachtbar zu sein
und das modell ist ja vielfach
übertragen worden das ist ja auch in
fabriken übertragen worden und wir haben
ja wenn wir uns alte fabriken angucken
sofern es ihn auch gibt im
ursprünglichen layout haben wir ja genau
das modell das die das zimmer des chefs
erhöht liegt mit blick oder
großraumbüros auch aus den 50er 60er
jahren und sowas und man sozusagen
diesen plan optischen blick hat jeden
mitarbeiter potenziell im blick zu haben
und das interessante an dass das
allerwichtigste dass potenzielle im
blick haben das heißt ja nicht ich werde
de facto 24 stunden beobachtet und de
facto dreht mir da jemand gleichen
strick draus das was ich mache aber mein
verhalten reguliert
nicht deshalb weil ich beobachtet werden
kann die potenziale und da können wir
zurückkommen auf den begriff des
privaten
wenn es tatsächlich so ist stellen wir
es uns so vor man muss in zehn jahren 20
jahren freiwillig oder unfreiwillig in
diesem smart homes leben und alles ist
vernetzt der weg zur arbeit von der
arbeit alles das was wir vorher schon
besprochen haben dann ist die potenziale
des vollständigen überwacht science in
jeder lebensregel einfach da und zwar
völlig unabhängig ob ich jetzt den
verdacht habe damit macht jemand etwas
böses oder die machen das alles nur zu
meinem besten über dinge wie das dass
die die selbstüberwachung über diese
neuen armbänder dieses selbst diese
tracking und self enhancing und
verbindung zur versicherungswirtschaft
haben wir noch gar nicht gesprochen
und warum sprechen wir nicht darüber
weil die entwicklung so vielfältig ist
und so irrsinnig schnell ist dass man
gar nicht dazu kommt dann alles
gleichzeitig zu denken das ist ja völlig
verrückt und er wählte sie sind extrem
erfolgreich sich haben zwei jahre benita
zion also eigentlich zwei professoren
titel
sie haben ihre akademische karriere und
den nagel gehängt um eine stiftung zur
zwei zu gründen diese zu leiten darüber
möchte ich mit ihnen nachher gleich noch
sprechen am main punkt ist sie können
sich diese haltung leisten sie sind
gefragt man findet sie auch wenn sie
kein handy haben die rufen sie hat anna
stiftung aber so und so viele leute
können sich doch diese ganze haltung
überhaupt nicht leisten
also ist es nicht ein bisschen so dass
sie von sehr hoher warte aus dass gute
predigen für viele die sich überhaupt
nicht wehren können
ich würde es ganz anders argumentieren
sie haben natürlich vollkommen recht
dass ich eine extrem privilegierte
stellung in der gesellschaft habe ja und
ich habe auch insofern eine
privilegierte stellung gehabt als ich
das privileg hatte eine akademische
ausbildung zu haben dass sich das
privileg hatte viele jahrzehnte an
universitäten und forschungsinstituten
zu arbeiten und sonst was
und ich würde einfach sagen daraus
leitet sich eine verpflichtung ab das
sind ja dinge die mir diese gesellschaft
gegeben hat und die konnte sie mir
deswegen geben weil sie ein
selbstverständnis gehabt
hat das in einer freien gesellschaft
menschen frei sind und gemäß ihrer
chancen sich entfalten können müssen
ganz klassisches modell westliches
sozialstaats modell der nachkriegszeit
so ich habe das genießen dürfen und ich
empfinde das wirklich als extremes
privileg und bin total dankbar dafür
deshalb nicht selbstlos das ist einfach
so wie es ist und weil ich diesen typ
von gesellschaft sehr schätze und in
vielerlei hinsicht moralisch aber auch
sozusagen von der chancenverteilung die
bislang beste gesellschaft halte dieses
historisch gegeben hat finde ich besteht
alle notwendigkeit diese gesellschaft zu
verteidigen
und dann kommen wir wieder auf den punkt
des privaten zurück und sozusagen das
der figur der bürgerinnen oder des
bürgers was haben wir denn wenn wir den
abschaffen den autonomen bürger wie
sieht dann eine solche gesellschaft
aussieht die dann so aus wie sich das
jemand im silicon valley aus denkt was
er als wünschenswerten konsumenten oder
konsumenten haben will den man jeden
mist andrehen kann bloß weil die ganze
redundanz maschine das internet so
funktioniert dass er genau die angebote
bekommt von denen wir dann wissen dass
er sie haben will und deshalb nie mehr
aus diesem diesem max weber hieß das
gehäuse der hörigkeit ja aber bezogen
auf das frühe zwanzigsten jahrhundert
was ist das für ein gehäuse der
hörigkeit was hier entsteht ist die
schwierigkeit nicht dieses ganzen dieses
kurses ein bisschen dass das eine das
perfekte beispiel ist für diese kunst
der ergebnislosen debatte sie sind
derjenige der wand der sagt da kommt was
ganz schlimmes bürger und bürgerinnen
zeit mündig thema selbst denken war ihr
letztes buch wehrt euch währenddessen
ganz viele andere entweder sagen kauft
kauft kauft surft oder auch einfach ist
mir einfach schlug bei mir geht's im
moment gut also erst mal vielleicht
anders gefragt glauben sie wirklich es
ist fortschritt in dieser debatte
möglich ja das glaube ich allerdings
also sie haben folgendes beispiel
trojanow juli zeh genommen für mich war
das eines der frustrierendsten
ergebnisse dass dort 500
schriftstellerinnen und schriftsteller
diesen aufruf unterzeichnet haben und
die politik sich bis auf eine kleine
anhörung im deutschen bundestag
überhaupt nicht dafür interessiert hat
da kann man sagen frustriert der befund
den sie eben skizziert haben und
interessiert sich kein mensch dafür
wir wissen aber aus allen sozialen
bewegungen die es bislang gegeben hat
dass die lange dauern und ist das
frustrierend ist ja es gibt aber
manchmal dann augenblicke in denen das
kippt so und wo wo sich mehr menschen
anschließen den besorgnissen oder den
widerstandsbewegungen dieser anderen und
in so einer situation befinden wir uns
im augenblick ich würde gar nicht davon
ausgehen dass man jetzt in
sekundenschnelle eine bewegung für
demokratie gegen die machtübernahme des
internets oder so was auf die beine
stellen weil ich sehe nicht dass wir uns
im moment in so einer zeit befinden also
wenn man guckt wie viele stunden
youtube-videos täglich hochgeladen
werden das ist ja gigantisch wie viel
zeit die menschen verbringen im internet
da ist doch keine soziale bewegung im
moment im ach so sie sagen es gibt diese
bewegung nicht nein die gibt es noch
nicht ich habe dich gemacht nicht ich
bin auch nicht so naiv zu sagen die
kommt jetzt nächstes jahr oder so aber
wie sie jetzt sich formieren denken sie
sie wird ihre zeit brauchen an sie ist
mit dem problem konfrontiert dass die
entwicklung wahnsinnig schnell ist
vielleicht ist das was neues was solche
formen von gegenbewegungen angeht aber
ich würde auch sagen vielleicht muss man
auch mal gucken welche und welches
unbehagen menschen verspüren und wie sie
darauf reagieren und da kann es dann
manchmal auch ganz hilflos sein wenn man
diesem unbehagen an ein argument gibt ja
an der stelle wo ich jetzt zum ersten
mal gesagt habe das hat was mit
totalitarismus zu tun was dort passiert
sagen natürlich alle der spinnt ja ja
der steve jobs ist ja nicht pol pot oder
sowas in der art aber man fängt an auf
eine andere art und weise über das thema
zu diskutieren und wenn man sagt unsere
grund verhältnisse in der demokratie
unsere grund verhältnisse des sozialen
beginnen sich zu verändern
empfangen leute an anders darüber zu
diskutieren oder nachzudenken es rückt
einmal ein bisschen dichter als wir
haben datenschutzproblemen das wäre die
einfachere variante aber sie sagen auch
ein stück weit ist ein problem das
argument es irgendwie zu wenig bewegen
was sie auch tun müssen ist geschichten
erzählen das tun sie mit foto 2 das ist
ihr ziel sie erzählen positive beispiele
was genau sollen damit passieren wo das
passiert man mit positiven beispiel
verändert man eine menge und das was bei
42 geschieht spielt sich ja jetzt
zunächst mal in einem raum ab der über
die veränderung von gesellschaft in
ökologischer hinsicht im weitesten sinne
nachdenkt ja das ist die absicht von
futter zwei geschichten darüber zu
erzählen wie man handlungsspielräume
dazu nutzen kann anders zu produzieren
anders zu leben besser mit ressorts so
ein konkretes zeichen ganz konkretes
beispiel also wenn ich zum beispiel eine
geschichte höhere über den
österreichischen schuhfabrikanten heini
staudinger der in seiner fabrik
nachhaltig produziert indem man nur
materialien aus der region verwendet die
zulieferer der ein gehaltsgefüge hat wo
er als der chef am wenigsten verdient
weil er sagt er hat den besten job also
ist es doch richtig wenn er am wenigsten
verdient und diejenige die schlechteste
arbeit macht am meisten verdient der
seine mitarbeiter mit gemüse und
nahrungsmitteln aus den umliegenden
biohöfen versorgt und der im grunde
genommen eine ländliche struktur politik
im waldviertel macht die wahnsinnig
erfolgreich ist so dann hat er weil sie
gefragt haben was ist daran gut würde
sagen gut daran erst das er zeigt wie
man handlungsspielräume nutzen kann was
der macht ist nämlich etwas wo jeder
sonst sagen würde das geht doch nicht
und dass er unser standard argument das
geht ja nicht wir erzählen bei futter
zwei geschichten darüber was geht und
das ist glaube ich wichtig weil wir
verlernt haben uns über unsere eigenen
handlungsspielraum rechenschaft
abzulegen weil sie natürlich viel zu
bequemer ist zu sagen ich kann nichts
machen
dafür nutzen sie aber das internet
wir nutzen dafür das internet natürlich
auch das heißt sie hoffen dass die leute
surfen und sie fiel
um diese geschichten lesen teilen weiter
erzählen wir ja schon aber das super
stichwort das wirklich wichtige ist das
weitererzählen und das wichtige ist die
lebendigkeit deshalb erzählen wir auch
geschichten geschichten erzählen ist
sicherlich eines der aller ältesten
medien und kultur techniken die die
menschheitsgeschichte erfunden hat wir
verstehen uns selbst im medium der
geschichte wir verstehen die anderen im
medium der geschichte die frage ist ja
auch immer wie gehen die um mit diesen
mythen oder geschichten normative sagt
man heute wie kann man die so platzieren
dass sie eine wirkung entfalten
da gibt's ja das interessante beispiel
der produktionsfirma partie 17 media die
diesen film über snowden gemacht hat sie
diesen vor den oscar gewonnen hat für
den besten dokumentarfilm dieses jahr
und diese produktionsfirma sagt wir
wollen mit filmen die welt verändern
nahmen das beispiel war inconvenient
truth mit am ball muss um den
klimawandel ding ein anderes beispiel
das immer nennen sind ist das phänomen
dass wir in irgendeine us-amerikanische
spital serie organspende thematisiert
schnellen die organspende nachher hoch
also viele positive beispiele
ich sage jetzt mal ganz platt ich habe
mir lange zeit gerne solche beispiele
angehört filme gucken ohnehin gerne aber
es gibt doch auch dieses phänomen das
man denkt ja mein gott schön zu lesen
aber damit verändern jedoch nicht die
welt da müsste es doch darum gehen an
den institutionen zu schrauben
aber wer schraubt an den institutionen
also auch darüber kann man geschichten
erzählen über menschen die in einem
dezernat sitzen und die
verkehrsinfrastruktur der stadt wurde
das dezernat ist beginnt zu verhindern
oder den gebrauch von energie oder die
arbeitsweise der städtischen wasserwerke
oder die pflege der grünanlagen ich
meine dafür gibt es wahnsinnig viele
gute geschichten die deshalb auch so
interessant sind weil das immer die
ausnahme sind weil die meisten menschen
machen das was die meisten menschen
machen und für uns ist das interessant
ist dass es immer jemanden gibt der sagt
nur ich probiere jetzt mal was anderes
also dieses thema von geht doch und
dieses geht doch findet findet futur 2
und finde ich
optisch wichtig weil es wege aufzeigt
wie was mit autonomie zu tun haben wenn
ich sage geht doch dann nehme ich ja
bezug auf meine fähigkeit und meine
persönlichkeit und sage das geht und
wenn es dann geht dann mache eine extrem
positive erfahrung
ihr habt selbstwirksamkeit erfahrung und
die ist für menschen wahnsinnig wichtig
weil sie saß positiv erleben und das
dann wiederholen wollen das heißt man
kann autonomien gewisser weise auch ein
üben deshalb erzählen wir diese
geschichte haben sie sich denn für
besonders autonom würde sich eine frage
die man nicht beantworten kann ich bin
sicherlich in vielen stellen in meinem
leben conformis tisch gewesen und
konformität hat ja auch seinen guten
sinn es ist ja nicht so dass wir jeden
morgen aufstehen und die welt neu
erfinden sondern vieles sehr vieles von
dem was wir tun ist das was wir immer
tun oder wo wir an anderen orientieren
das ist ja auch sinnvoll da muss man
nicht so viel aufwand treiben aber es
hat eben die kehrseite bei negativen
entwicklungen dass das was alle tun dazu
tendiert das falsche zu sein
sie sind ja selber sieht man in diesem
buch selbst denken auch sehr schön sehr
stark in dieser öko bewegung zu hause
das etwas was ihm sehr am herzen liegt
was andere große stichwort ist der
klimawandel und daneben das netz sie
sagen ihn selbst denken und sich selber
sie sind überhaupt nicht in einen öko
nahen haushalt aufgewachsen ihre familie
ist nicht irgendwie ökologisch
imprägniert gewesen was hat sie denn
politisiert zum ökologisch bewussten
wäre gemacht
ja ich würde sagen ja es gab eine sehr
frühe phase dieser ökologischen
politisierung da war ich noch schüler
und da gibt es große auseinandersetzung
über die zivile nutzung von atomenergie
na ja es gab eine anti atomkraft
bewegung und das war für mich eigentlich
die erste phase mich für im weitesten
sinne ökologische fragestellungen
energie fragestellung zu interessieren
aber eben auch eine faszination teil
einer bewegung zu sein die gegen etwas
ist und ihn zwar gegen etwas ist aber
die eine massenbewegung ist oder da
klärt auch wieder das
zusammengehörigkeit
aber es ist ja ein unterschied ob ich
ein zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl habe oder
ob ich teil einer massenbewegung in die
die vorwiegend jugendliche bewegung die
dort auf den straßen oder vor den
bauplätzen für atomkraftwerke
demonstriert hat war ja eine extrem
kleiner teil der bevölkerung selbst wenn
da mal 50.000 100.000 demonstriert haben
ist es natürlich ganz wenig im vergleich
zur gesamtbevölkerung keine
massenbewegung aber natürlich die
erfahrung etwas gemeinsam zu tun und das
ist ein ganz starker unterschied ich
glaube auch dass zur sozialen bewegungen
immer dazu gehört nicht nur dass man so
denkt oder wissenschaftlich sich
angeeignet hat um dann argumentieren zu
können sondern auch das gefühl in
direkter und eben nicht virtueller
gemeinsamkeit an einem ziel zu arbeiten
und auch gegen andere mit konflikten an
so einem ziel zu arbeiten eine ganz
zentrale erfahrung die extrem wichtig
ist aber um auf ihre frage
zurückzukommen ich habe dann eigentlich
erst viel später diesen faden wieder
aufgenommen und zwar über die verbindung
zur gewaltforschung ich habe mich hier
sehr viel mit gewalt beschäftigt dem
zusammenhang taucht ja auch das medium
experiment auf und ich habe mir
irgendwann mal die frage gestellt als
ich gewissermaßen als interessierter
bürger alle die ergebnisse der
klimaforschung gesehen habe und gedacht
habe das ist ja alles fürchterlich was
bedeutet das denn eigentlich für
künftige konflikte und auf dem weg dann
habe ich eine studie dazu gemacht über
klimawandel und gewaltkonflikte und auf
dem weg bin ich gewissermaßen
ökologisiert und dann haben sie in einem
spiegel artikel gesagt sie hätten selber
ein stück weit ein problem sie hätten
nämlich wahnsinnig gerne autos drei
autos hatten sie zumindest damals
übrigens heute nur noch 1 nur noch 1 und
waren sie damit runden ganz selten so
dass er wollen wir mal festhalten
sie haben selber auch einen sohn der ist
mittlerweile über 20 also den muss man
nicht mehr ziehen durfte der cola und
kind haben wir selbstverständlich keine
verbote keine verbote
also das heißt total antiautoritär
erzogen
ja ich würde das nicht als antiautoritär
bezeichnen weil gar nicht die ab
dicht dahinter gestanden hat das hängt
natürlich immer sehr stark auch von den
persönlichkeiten auch von kindern ab was
für sie am besten ist und mein sohn ist
jemand der sehr autonom ist und in
gewisser weise immer gewesen ist also
den das größte scheitern was ich in
meinem leben mit ihm erlebt habe war
dass er sich geweigert hat sich das
fahrrad für ihr fahren beibringen zu
lassen mit drei oder vier
und ich habe gemerkt dass jeder versuch
wenn ich da weiter unternehmen weil ich
für unwahrscheinlich gerne fahrrad und
ich wollte das total gerne nur zu immer
mehr widerstand führt also ich mir
gedacht na ja dann lerne halt nicht
fahrrad fahren was soll das ganze
natürlich fährt er inzwischen fahrrad
aber aus eigener entscheidung her
und glücklicherweise ist ist er von
seiner persönlichkeit her so dass er
sich selber sein leben wahnsinnig gut
organisieren kann und eingriffe
eigentlich eher schädlich gewesen wir
haben und im grunde genommen ist das ja
ein pädagogisches grundprinzip glaube
ich dass man eigentlich ja nur
entwicklungsumgebung zur verfügung
stellen muss in denen sich die
potenziale entfalten können wir machen
ja aber das ist jetzt ein ganz anderes
thema im grunde haben mit diesem bösen
wort der drohnen pädagogik wo man
ständig darüber nachdenkt was jetzt das
beste für das kind sein könnte und immer
noch experten zu rate zieht und
pädagogisch wertvolles spielzeug und so
weiter schafft man ja keine
entwicklungsumgebung für autonomie
sondern mannschaft eine in der das kind
sich kaum noch bewegen kann das war nie
meine vorstellung aber man muss
natürlich auch dann entsprechend mit
einer kindlichen persönlichkeit zu tun
haben die das auch gut vertragen kann es
gibt sicherlich kinder die es besser
finden wenn sie etwas mehr anleitung
kurz sind ja eine person die gerne
selber steuert sie haben am letzten
montag ein interview gegeben bei fokus
auf srf 3 und da haben sie sich einen
sohn gewünscht einer berliner band die
ich nicht kannte
und da ist mir der satz hängen geblieben
er eben die so was wie ich springe nicht
auf den fahrenden zug ich fahre selbst
das sind sie oder
ich das so nicht von mir ja aber es ist
so ungefähr wahrscheinlich ihr
lebensmotto sie steuern gerne selber ich
weiß gar nicht ob man das so sagen kann
ich habe zb das ist ja bei menschen
immer sehr ambivalent ich habe viele
situationen wo ich das geradezu als
zumutung empfinden mich entscheiden zu
müssen ja aus tausend produkten
auswählen zu müssen oder selbst im
restaurant habe ich manchmal so das
gefühl ich finde es viel besser wenn
nebenan jemand sagt du ist jetzt das und
das ja also es ist nicht so dass ich
total scharf drauf bin pausenlos alles
selber zu entscheiden
die frage ist natürlich nur arena der
algorithmus macht das ja jetzt für sie
aber dagegen wehren sie sich wieder ja
ja genau genau ich möchte ja nicht eine
einem programmierer gewissermaßen die
die herrschaft über mich über antworten
wenn ich mit einer person die ich direkt
kenne sozusagen eine entscheidung
delegiere dann mache ich das ja weil ich
da vertrauen zu haben oder weil ich
denke die können das für mich viel
besser entscheiden als ich das für mich
selber kenne ich bin dann mit dem essen
zufrieden aber das ist eine vollkommen
andere ausgangssituation was sie nicht
sind sie wenn ich ihre bücher lese schon
so ein bisschen ein eher revolution
stück weit auch sie sagen zu vielen
dingen nein danke das will ich nicht und
versuchen die anderen auch dazu zu
bringen sich zumindest darüber gedanken
zu machen ob sie es wirklich wollen und
sie sich gut überlegt haben an einem
punkt gehen sie für mich zu weit sie
sagen ich gehe nicht mehr wählen
erklären sie mal nein das ist ja ein
mythos
haben sie geschrieben in einem artikel
im spiegel 2013 genau warum ich nicht
mehr wählen gehen und das war ja so ein
essay in dem ich das für die situation
der bundestagswahl 2013 anhand der wie
ich fand zukunfts vergessenheit der
parteien und ihrer programme versucht
habe darzulegen
der spannende punkt war dass dieser
essay tatsächlich zu einer debatte
geführt hat das haben sich viele
politiker dazu geäußert jürgen trittin
von den grünen hat an gegen artikel
geschrieben zwei wochen später und so
weiter und so weiter es gab eine debatte
und die debatte war insofern unheimlich
interessant
weil sie eigentlich um die frage sich
gedreht hat ist demokratie
kreuzchenmachen demokratie etwas mehr
als kreuzchen machen und ist es dann
legitim zu sagen jetzt will ich mal
nicht oder so was
und das fand ich unheimlich teuer und
als der wahltag gekommen das habe ich
gedacht na jetzt kann ich ja auch wählen
gehen weil wir haben ein gewisser bei so
einer situation mehr gemacht als das
kreuzchen und ich bin ja nicht
prinzipiell gegen das wählen
ich bin nur gegen sozusagen arroganz von
parteien politik ich meine zum beispiel
damit dass dann sofort auch eine eine
teil der debatte von politischer seite
so gewesen ist dass das arrogante
intellektuelle sind die jetzt irgendwie
sagen wir gehen nicht mehr wählen das
ein zeichen von arroganz das haben sich
ja andere richard david precht peter
sloterdijk und so war damals ganz
ähnlich geäußert und die situation die
reaktion auf seiten der politik die war
ja gemeint war eine abwehr
es sind arrogante blöde elitäre leute
die missachten die demokratie neulich
hat sogar noch die deutsche kultur
staatsministerin in einer öffentlichen
rede gesagt wir seien demokratie
verächter und das fand ich absolut
skandalös weil wenn ich über demokratie
diskutieren
dann lässt sich doch wohl das schwer als
etwas verächtliches bezeichnen
das sind die vielleicht mehr
schweizerinnen und schweizer auch noch
spezielle empfindlich mit der sehr
direkten demokratie der möglichkeit bei
der neben partizipieren kann es ja immer
einfach zu sagen entschuldigung ich mach
da nicht mit weil das was da läuft
gefällt mir nicht immerhin kann man sich
beteiligen
ich würde gerne wenn wir jetzt das ganze
gespräch noch einmal an blicken noch mit
einem gedanken kommen ist in dieser
ganzen debatte immer wieder bezug
genommen auf dieses auto renault zitat
es gibt kein richtiges leben im falschen
und der blogger christian heller hat er
mal gesagt es gibt kein analoges leben
in digitalen darf man das sogleich
setzen ist das digitale jetzt das
falsche und die müssen um das richtige
wieder irgendwie kämpfen
oder gibt es auch das richtige digitale
das klug verwendete digitale also ich
würde sagen es wäre vollkommen typen
so eine maschinenstürmer position zu
haben also wenn ich jetzt aus meinen
argumenten und gedanken den schluss
ziehen würde
wir müssen das alles digitale abschaffen
weil das ist teufelswerk oder so das
natürlich blöd sind es sind auch
historisch blödsinn weil natürlich jede
form von neuer kommunikationstechnologie
und auch die gutenberg-bibel war eine
kommunikationstechnologie oder die
schallplatte ist eine
kommunikationstechnologie und so weiter
jeder einführung solcher neuen
technologien zu besorgnissen geführt hat
aber auch zur regulierungs bedürfnissen
geführt hat und wir haben im moment so
eine entwicklung die eben sehr sehr
eingreifend ist in einem in ihrer
dimension und relativ wenig
gegenbewegung alles das was wir schon
diskutiert haben daraus würde ich nicht
den schluss ziehen dass man das
abschaffen könnte und müsste aber man
muss ja eine referenz haben eine art von
werther korsett zu sagen an dieser
stelle ist das so übergriffig dass ich
intervenieren muss und da ist natürlich
die politik und der gesetzgeber gefragt
beziehungsweise ist einfach auch nur
gefragt dass man solche dinge wie die
unverletzlichkeit der person und der
wohnung und sowas ernst nimmt das steht
in den verfassungen drin
deshalb bin ich auch gar nicht der
meinung es ist alles so komplex wir
haben jetzt die schwierigkeit neue
gesetze zu schaffen nein man muss nur
die anwenden die es schon gibt und auch
entsprechend in den parlamenten darüber
diskutieren was da vor sich hat so was
wie die ganze rede vom digitalen
menschenrechten dies bräuchten neue form
von menschen rechnet das hatten sie
nicht
nein ich glaube es ist vollkommen
ausreichend sich auf die
verfassungshüter zu beziehen und
natürlich auf der operativen ebene wie
setze ich das jetzt durch im fall xy
gegen das und das unternehmen da muss
man wahrscheinlich dass entsprechend
juristisch ausfallen und nachbessern
aber grundsätzlich geht es eigentlich um
die werte entscheidung finde ich
demokratie gut wie wir sie haben möchte
ich sie verteidigen wo wird sie
angegriffen an wenn ich sehe sie wird
angegriffen und zwar zum teil auch sehr
kaltschnäuzig angegriffen
dann würde ich sagen dann sind wir
gefordert als politische bürger zu sagen
nein das wollen wir nicht
und gerade da haben natürlich viele
internet befürworter gesagt haben wir
eben neue instrumente um die demokratie
wieder zu stärken also stichwort liquid
democracy
die ganze bewegung der piratenpartei die
gesagt haben leute wir holen euch ins
boot dank des internets finden sie das
nicht
das finde ich nicht naiv die frage ist
immer nur wir können das ganze noch mal
unter einem anderen begriff diskutieren
nämlich unter dem begriff der macht ja
das interessante ist ja dass diese
technologien konzernen macht chancen
gegeben haben mit denen die niemals
gerechnet haben wir hatten das thema ja
auch vorhin das schleicht sich so
langsam in das leben ein
und wahrscheinlich hat steve jobs und
seiner garage niemals daran gedacht dass
das fantastisch ist alle menschen jemals
ausforschen zu können das ist etwas was
im prozess entsteht damit steigert sich
akkumuliert sich macht auf seiten der
jenigen die so macht ausüben können es
wäre völlig irrational wenn die die ich
nutzen würden
auf der anderen seite and mächtigen wir
uns wenn es nichts privates mehr gibt
wenn alles durchschaut werden kann wenn
wir uns nicht mehr organisieren können
ohne dass es jemand merkt und soja das
sind insofern muss man diese fragen auch
im sinne von macht diskutieren damit man
auch versteht dass man gegen macht
entwickeln muss so und wenn das
funktioniert und die politik diesmal
langsam begreift dann würden wir
regulierungen haben wo man sagt
bestimmte eingriffe gibt es nicht
bestimmte daten werden gar nicht erhoben
also wir müssen auch darüber diskutieren
was man gar nicht erst erhebt bevor man
darüber nachdenkt was man schützenfest
der welt zum schluss die zitieren oft
noch einmal adorno nur die übertreibung
ist wahr
übertreiben sie ein bisschen ja
wahrscheinlich schon aber mit adorno
glaube ich wirklich das ist auch eine
erkenntnis instrument ich würde ja sagen
wir mal vorhin über verantwortung von
leuten ja die sonne so eine position
haben wie ich gesprochen
naja ich muss das doch nutzen um das
etwas weiter zu denken
und nicht immer hinter dem gegenwarts
punkt zu bleiben man muss doch über den
gegensatz punkt hinaus und zu sagen da
gibt es genau diese potentially tät und
zwar deswegen weil es dann noch der
moment wo man dagegen vorgehen kann
hinterher ist man zwar immer schlauer
aber man kann nichts mehr machen
ein plädoyer fürs übertreiben ich danke
ihnen herr welt sehr gerne am karfreitag
wie mein kollege stephan klapproth hoch
hinaus zu 150 jahrestag der matterhorn
erstbesteigung lädt er zum
philosophischen gitter gespräch mit den
beiden bergsteigern die steck und
evelyne binsack und dem höhen mediziner
oswald oelz jetzt aber erst mal einen
schönen sonntag
[Musik]
und nun zur kunst